I would be really surprised if life in
the universe uses DNA but I wouldn't be
surprised if it uses carbon because
that's a more fundamental molecule it's
very common it's a lot more common in
the universe than silicon water is
likewise a very common solvent and it
has some unique properties water and
carbon to me are more fundamental units
than say DNA which is a lot more
complicated and probably wasn't even in
Earth's earliest life Dr soon to be
Professor Sarah Rimer welcome to the
into the impossible podcast how are you
today I'm doing great thank you for
having me so great to have you I just uh
absolutely devoured your book audio book
which is an audible exclusive we're
going to talk a lot about that uh and I
want to just read a brief bio if I read
the whole bio you're so impressive Sarah
that it will take the whole hour that
you have generously and graciously and
allotted me but currently your Sarah
Rimer is an astrophysicist at Oxford
working on how to detect life on an
exoplanet by look exoplanet atmospheric
bio signatures uh in 2020 she was
selected as a Ted fellow and she has a
wonderful Ted Talk which has been seen
by almost a million people in just a
couple of weeks and you can find that
it's called searching for microscopic
aliens I'll put a link to that here
maybe we'll put some highlight they do a
great job and your wonderful audio book
is an Amazon audible original searching
for extraterrestrial life and I wanted
to start there with Amazon because as
you know today was the first voyage of
the new Shepherd spacecraft piloted by
the proprietor of Amazon uh Mr Jeff
Bezos and his brother and uh an
astronaut named Wally um Funk who was uh
one of the original Mercury 13 I think
and uh so there was life in space for a
little bit today and actually I want to
uh get your impression about where we
should be going if you looked at aliens
looking at us today they would have seen
you know four people heading towards
them that's an interesting question I
kind of view them as separate and in
some ways a bit contradictory uh so I'm
really excited about Wally FK you know
she's the oldest uh astronaut now 82
years old part of the Mercury 13 program
really excited for her to have lived out
that lifelong dream and then there's
this tension though because we have you
know people from the private sector who
can just put whatever they want into
space say um you know like satellites
and uh you know the the is it the
Starling from from Elon Musk and and
whatnot and I would say there's some
tension then between the scientific
community and how that would influence
our observations or what I'm worried
about as an astrobiologist is I really
I'm pro-human exploration of space
absolutely we're explorers I do I climb
mountains I climb mountains just because
they're there I am definitely Pro human
space exploration on the long term but
I'm really worried that we're going to
screw up our ability to study the red
planet especially Mars if we send humans
there prematurely so if we go there
before we can actually explore it to see
if there was life or if there is current
life under the subsurface if we instead
contaminate it with us and all the
hearty microbes we bring from Earth so
this month we've had on several
different scientists uh from around the
planet talking about life entropy the
origin of life um and and even the
definition of life I mean I go back to
NASA's working definition because it is
just very convenient of course we don't
really know cuz we're still hampered by
the one example of life that we have on
Earth which is Earth life uh so you know
this idea of a self-sustained chemical
system capable of undergoing darwinian
Evolution there's a few very broad
things I like about that definition one
of them being that it is chemical that
it can evolve and uh you know that those
things I think are are interesting
however what if we come across you know
artificial intelligence that's quote
unquote pass might be alive that life
would not be included under that
definition and when we think about um
you know the yeah as Max tegar calls
life 3.0 artificial intelligence uh what
do you make of the fact that we've been
very much focused literally and
figuratively in some cases my colleague
Professor Shelley Wright here searching
for optical signals from seti uh from
Advanced extraterrestrial intelligence
um what about this prediliction that
mostly SEI has been about looking for
technology our techn signatures is that
just because that you kind of look for
your keys under the lamp post as the old
joke goes or do we should we pay more
attention to the kinds of signals
signatures that you look on from the
tiniest aliens in the universe well in
the short answer is we should do both I
don't think there that's at odds with
each other uh certainly I think we have
if you look at the history of life on
Earth life has been on Earth basically
as soon as Earth was habitable we have
Signs of Life dating back very dating
back very far in Earth's history and
then it was single cellular for most of
Earth's history and it's really only in
the last you know billion years that
it's been more than one celled type of
life and then even just in the last
hundred years that it's been
technological us and so you know when we
think of Earth as a if it is a
representative planet for most time we
would have seen the microbial biosphere
so I think that is our best chance for
finding life in the Solar uh in the
universe sorry not the solar system also
in the solar system I think we might
find microbial life uh but in the in the
universe and other planets however we
should also search for intelligence
signals because that is definitely a
clearer signal if someone waves at you
and says hello we are here I want to
first take a step back in your past
World line where you come from where
you've been uh you're from Montana you
make no secret of that you mention it
with a great deal of Montana Pride I I
know most of what I know about Montana
from the TV show Yellowstone uh so so
and I I hope that's not representative
that's kind of like Sopranos move from
New Jersey and go to Montana but if you
haven't seen it but the other thing I
think about Montana a lot is like
looking for fossils and dinosaurs and so
forth and I want to ask you know was
that part of what's in your intellectual
DNA this search for for ancient signals
did that arise in part because of your
unique the unique place that you came
from bosan Montana town of what 50,000
people I don't think it did though in
hindsight one could see how you might
describe that so my dad was a physics
professor at Montana State University
and in fact we did he would uh do talks
for the local Museum and then they would
send us on dinosaur digs in the summer
for free like that was his exchange with
with the museum and so you know as a kid
I did go out into eastern Montana and
just you know try to use uh like little
brushes and and chisels to see if I
could find dinosaur bones found a few it
was
exciting I didn't become a
paleontologist you know and and then in
the end I didn't even want to be uh a
physicist so my dad was a physics
Professor my brother is also a physics
Professor all of all of his children
have a degree in physics of some sort
and so I really told my dad I was like
I'm never ever G to take a physics class
as long as I live I hope you're okay
with that and my dad was always
supportive he's like you got a major in
what you want to major in and so I don't
know I think I was going in thinking
about robotic engineering you know in in
my first year at a community college in
Montana and then I looked back well I
mean I guess it's first before that I
didn't even want to take physics I took
accounting instead and that was really
boring in high school long story short I
switched out of accounting the only
class that would take me that late in
the semester was physics I loved it and
then here I am that's that's the short
story of it but I realized at some point
it was stupid not to go into physics
just because a lot of my family had gone
into physics and kind of rediscovered it
for myself and then I made the same sort
of declarative statements against
astronomy while I was in undergrad I was
like oh no I'm never going to become an
astronomer and here I am yeah you went
from accounting the next uh major uh
alphabetically was astronomy so uh here
you are um so on the cover of searching
for extraterrestrial life in the audible
uh bookstore uh there is a picture of an
unidentified flying object uh a flying
saucer shall we say it looks to be
pretty well uh identified very very
clear techno signature in the last month
alone uh I've had you know several
different guests on from Michael Shermer
to uh to Seth Shak uh earlier in the
year I had Jill Tarter Sarah Seager uh
what is this fascination with uh uh UFOs
as alien craft I mean that seems to be a
pretty big leap in a lot of ways and
then there a lot of my listeners right
now are screaming at me no that's the
most likely explanation so we have a
very aidite audience very diverse
but um but tell me what is it about um
about this topic that immediately
conjures up flying saucers so much so
that you have this very clickable not
clickable head uh cover picture on your
Audi book of a UFO when you really spend
a lot of your time looking for
microscopic thing yeah I mean great
question certainly I have no input into
what Amazon puts on the cover of these
things uh but when we think about these
recent Pentagon videos I watched uh your
some of your podcasts on that some of
the the podcast for example with Mick
West you know debating the origin of
some of these uh features and and I
think there's a couple things that I
think capture us so one is we really
want to not be alone and so even if we
find life on another planet and it's
microbial life that's that to me is
amazing and that would be just the
discovery of the human kind however we
might still feel lonely you know if we
just find other microbes on another rock
it's not like we can really commun Comm
unicate with that it's similarly if we
find even you know a crow or like
something like a bird we can't talk to
that about our uh you know sort of our
esoteric and big questions about why are
we here and and how you know how did the
universe begin and all these things we
can't like test our theories against
them so I think we really want to find
life that we can communicate with and so
there is this uh push to try to validate
and believe I would say we have this
biased it's a bias stronger than the
confirmation bias of course we see what
we want to see that's a very well-known
bias we really have to pay attention to
that but then there's also the bias of
just believing what we want to believe
to be true and and so that's also a very
strong bias and I think I think we see
that play out in these uh trying to
identify these aerial phenomenon because
all of them really have shown to be
relatively boring Earth phenomenon uh
you know as far as we know and and I
think it's also would just say like we
we hold these unidentified objects at a
higher level of evidence threshold than
we do for murders you know we don't
solve all murders on Earth but we expect
to solve every single unknown Sky I mean
that seems a little bit uh ridiculous to
start pinning aliens on it yeah I view
that as a tribute to science and our
power of science as you point out you
know in the book If you ask the average
American how much does NASA's you know
budget what fraction of it of the US
budget they'll say yeah it's 50% 20% uh
and it's like less than 1% as you as you
accurately point out uh but so it's a
tribute that they think that we can
answer all these questions I always say
you know science means knowledge it
doesn't mean wisdom and there's a big
difference between the two but I think
part of the wisdom is knowing the impact
of the science that we do and I want to
take us back to the
1990s uh when uh you describe in the
book you know Bill Clinton had a press
conference uh following the discovery of
possible tentative signs of microbial
life on uh and a meteorite from Mars
that landed in Antarctica um and I I
just feel you know regret that the times
I've been in Antarctica I've never
picked up a meteorite Martian or
otherwise but nevertheless this
particular artifact made headlines
around the world in fact there's a scene
in the wonderful movie contact uh based
in part by one of my past guests andrean
and her late husband Carl Sean where
they have in the movie version they have
a press conference where President
Clinton's talking about the discovery of
these aliens that Ellie Arrow found
right and it's so prominent in people's
minds these discoveries first of all uh
I want to take I want to take two uh
aspects of this question to you pose two
two questions to you one is if we
discover that these were definitively
real microbial life forms from Mars uh
it seems to me the impact would be
pretty shortlived because most people
don't know that they've never been
confirmed or refuted right so as far as
most of the American public knows the
same public that believes 20% of our
budget goes to NASA they probably
believe that that there was Martian uh
DNA or some microbial life found right
so 30 years later 20 plus years later so
what do you think would be the long-term
impact if we found microbes versus
finding um you know a techn signature in
terms of a a spacecraft or you know or
or radio signal what what's the
differential impact between various
gradations of Life yeah I mean it's
excellent question it's it's something
you know as someone who really wants to
find evidence of life on another planet
whether it be microbial or complex or
intelligent you know I'm staking my
whole career on this this is what I you
know get up you know gets what gets me
out of bed so to speak and and one of
the sad things about this is I think
that people will be underwhelmed when we
actually come up with a discovery
because they're like oh didn't we
already discover microbes on mars or
didn't we already discover microbes in
Venus or didn't we already discover you
know wasn't it clear that those alien
signals and alien UFOs are real and and
so I think that people tend to already
believe there is life and so despite the
fact that we have no robust evidence for
life we just don't none of the evidence
that we have really crosses that
threshold to be considered robust uh
scientifically so then then we should be
excited if we do detect life but I think
a lot of people will have thought that
we already detected that and there's a
couple reasons for that some of it's
bias and media reporting how scientists
talk about things kind of a
misunderstanding of scientific evidence
and the scientific process but yeah so I
think that's one fear I have is that
when we do find evidence of life it
won't be met with the appropriate awe
that it should be for being one of the
most fascinating and profound
discoveries we could have in our life uh
and then of course yeah if we can
actually have any sort of technological
signal that we receive that would be
even more fascinating my thumbs rather
occupied right now holding up good old
Carl San but you yours is free to push
that like button and don't forget to
subscribe it really helps us with the
algorithm now back to the episode right
yeah I always say if you want to know
what it would be like right the day
after the discovery is confirmed
announced and you know at the White
House just you know go down to the beach
and scoop up some some uh water and
there'll be trillions of microbes in
there and uh pretty much people will
kind of move on with their day there are
people that say this would be the most
profound thing to discover microbes I I
tend to think not and the reason is just
look at the history of how awful we
treat life on Earth both animals and
humans right it's just it's just human
history is replete with the denigration
of human life as a value and I think
that's uh one of the worst aspects of
technology is a cheapening of human life
but anyway finding mic crubs you know
would be interesting I think to many
people but but you know what would be
the impact the next day it's hard to say
but you did bring up something very
important which is the way the media
cover things and I always have this you
know probably based on my experience
with bicep 2 and other things that I
talk about in my book uh is this issue
of you know the lead story is always
above the fold like literally above the
fold New York Times San Diego Union
Tribune you know Toronto Star Herald
whatever and then the retraction if it
ever comes if it ever comes is on the
Saturday edition page B17 nobody knows
about it nobody reads so I claim that
scientists should keep a budget and that
some of that budget should be for PR and
some of that budget should be held in
reserve as a hedge against the risk of
retractions and I think we owe it to the
public to not only trumpet what we think
are our theories and successes uh but uh
but you brought this up and I want to
get your take on it it's so Sensational
you go through very accurately and very
delightfully in the book The History of
that Martian CLA Martian find and I
didn't know half this stuff I mean I
knew almost nothing I just knew that it
hadn't been confirmed really and that uh
it was probably premature on the other
hand you go through it meticulously um
and I also remember there was an
announcement of uh Alien type life that
eats sulur and whatever found in Mono
Lake here in California again these are
peer-reviewed things these aren't just
like you know they're just you know
one-off things like some SCI scientist
they're good scientists you go through
their their their find and and yet so
what do we do about that what do we do
about the kind of type one versus type
two error risk to The credibility of
science that tends to proliferate both
in my field and in your field there's a
number of things that we should do and
and this is certainly relevant as we
even go right now through our age of
misinformation alternative facts and
false facts and all of all of this too
because there's a flood of information
on the internet and how to tease out
what is real and what's not is one
hurdle and then a separate hurdle is
even in these prominent Publications
like you said they publish the main
finding but they don't necessarily
publish the alternative uh you know
updated View once the scientific
Community had looked at it because with
any of these claims I guess if for your
audience they probably know that you're
going to have a huge press release
because it is an exciting Discovery it's
going to be embargoed which means a lot
of scientists haven't yet been able to
look at this discovery and then once you
put it out you're going to have a whole
bunch of people think about other things
that you forgot to think about and then
it's going to go through that process of
vetting and and maybe it'll be proved to
be true such as the Pulsar planets uh
you know the first exoplanets we kind of
forget about them and I feel sad because
they didn't win the Nobel Prize even
though they were the first exoplanets
discovered uh you know so we those were
eventually confirmed to be true even
though they weren't believed at the time
you know and then you have other things
like the Martian meteor which which
hasn't proved to be true uh but you
don't see the same level of media
attention paid to the other uh Parts
along that story so you know I think the
Venus we'll get to the Venus Discovery
but actually a lot of the follow up
studies on Venus have been published and
I've been and I've seen them kind more
prominently in the news so I'm excited
about that I think it allows the general
public to see the process of Science and
kind of understand it a little bit more
because I don't want people to come away
with thinking we don't know how to like
nothing's true no study you ever read is
true scientists don't know what they're
doing but I do want them to have you
know some skepticism while also having
that excitement at new discoveries and
retaining both of those things at the
same time you talked earlier about you
know kind of a working definition of
life you didn't actually make reference
to DNA or even carbon-based life you
talk in the book about um these things
that have a delightful name as an
acronym but are almost IM unpronouncable
poly aromatic cyclic hydrocarbon p is
also known as pause yeah let's just call
them pa um you speculate delightfully
about you know work that's been done
maybe there could be some version of DNA
as Schrodinger himself thought some
Crystal or something like that later
found to be not accurate but DNA instead
but talk about that the alternative life
not alternative facts but alternative
life um modalities that don't use DNA
RNA uh as you discussed in the book you
talk about the RNA World hypothesis
origin of Life talk about alternative
that was fascinating to me how could
ph's PS be candidates for encrypting and
coding genetic information like any
molecule that can link together and
contain information so you could think
of you know in DNA we have four
molecules RNA also has four molecules so
but you could imagine just like uh like
in computers a zero and a one that's
kind of the basic level of information
and so even if if you have just
molecules that can link together and
encode an onoff sort of switch it would
take maybe more of them to convey the
same amount of information is say if you
had four switches that you can relay
information through but you can imagine
information being propagated so I think
when we look at various origin scenarios
of life or indeed when we're trying to
find life in our solar system this is
definitely uh more applicable to solar
system exploration than exoplanets where
we're more limited by trying to look for
something we can understand but in the
solar system we want to be relatively
agnostic as to the type of biochemistry
it could be and so we want to look for
any type of complex biochemistry it
could not be based in the molecules that
we know so this is you know going away
from pause but if we look in Titan and
the liquid ethane and methane likes
there what if you had similar sorts of
uh like a totally different biochemistry
there than what we're used to but if it
can transmit information that and and
support life then that would be
fascinating but we just don't know yet
so so I think we don't yet know if the
phase face of life is open I would be
really surprised if life in the universe
uses DNA I think probably not
um but I wouldn't be surprised if it
uses carbon because that's a more
fundamental molecule that's uh very
common it's a lot more common in the
universe than silicon for example uh
water is likewise a very common solvent
and it has some unique properties more
common than liquid methane so I feel
like you know water and carbon to me are
more
fundamental units than say DNA which is
a lot more complicated and probably
wasn't even in Earth's earliest life you
maybe had RNA or precursors to DNA like
PNA or TNA or other uh information
caring systems so when we think about
yeah the sort of propensity to do uh to
be biased and Prejudiced as scientist
not just the invidious Prejudice of
sexism and racism that that does uh
still persist in some corners of
Academia and Science and astronomy
itself uh and you're Fierce advocate for
women and stem uh you also have the
honor of holding the Caroline hersel
she's one of the most Titanic
astronomers of any gender in human
history uh and here at UC San Diego we
had Margaret Burbage who also was I
believe overshadowed for a Nobel Prize
in favor of Willie fer and other people
um uh and she of course made the
fundamental contribution to the
observations that led to our model of
Stellar nucleosynthesis Beyond you know
sort of the lightest elements in the
periodic table but when we think about
looking elsewhere and and kind of the
bias that we have toward WS um what
looks like us as I say not just in terms
of our sociology but in terms of what
life could be um could phosphine
potentially fall into that because you
know the uh the the the paper and so
forth the work by Professor Jan Greaves
and and Cardiff and and her
collaborators Sarah Seager and and car
and others at MIT they are sort of
looking you know where the where the
light is in other words they know that
phosphine was a was a s bio signature of
life on Earth and so one it elsewhere so
what what is that what is that uh the
danger of these different biases
confirmation bias look elsewhere effect
you know the file drawer effect um you
know that that we suffer from as as
astronomers as physicists absolutely I
mean first I would say is in some ways
we are for exoplanets again not for our
solar system we are necessarily
hamstrung to look for things that we can
recognize so it could be that life
exists in the Clouds Of Jupiter for
example but if we can't tell if that's
true in our own solar system and we've
taken high resolution images of Jupiter
with Juno how are we going to see on an
exoplanet we just we just can't even
really comprehend what that bios
signature would be or similarly there
very well might be life under the uh ice
cap the ice ocean on Europa uh yet that
doesn't have an atmosphere and so as an
exoplanet it's it's relatively useless
to us so I think we need to look first
for Global biospheres that we could
would detect and so I think this is a
really common misconception actually in
the public as well as within the
scientific Community is when we say
habitable planets it's kind of a short
term for something that we could detect
from light years away it doesn't mean
that that's the only place that life
could exist and we know that you know
life could exist in many other places
within our own solar system but it's
just saying where could we actually have
a hope to detect this from light years
away now all bets are off when we look
in our own solar system because we can
actually go there we can send Landers we
can and Rovers we can look for this
other type of life and and so I think
that's where we should really test out
some of these alternative biochemistries
Venus is a great place to look if if
such weird life exists you know same
with Titan same with Mars Europa all of
these other places we should look there
because alternative biochemistries are
kind of if we can't prove them sort of
Institue here in in Earth or on planets
around us it's going to be really hard
to detect them on another planet like
and maybe we'll eventually get there and
I think we should keep our mind open so
I really appreciate the work of Sarah
Seager and other colleagues who are
trying to be more open to any type of
molecule we can find but Clara Susa
Silva who came up with the lines for
phosphine for example you know she's
trying to go through and create Spectra
for more of these molecules but we don't
even have the Spectra to detect them
right now there's like 16,000 molecules
that Earth life could produce and we
only have Spectra of even poor quality
for 0.4% of them so in some ways we only
looking for phosphine because Dr claraa
Silva made the lines for phosphine for
example and then we could suddenly look
for it we couldn't look for other
molecules that we don't have the lines
for and when when you look at the number
of high resolution line lists that exist
there's just not that many yet so this
is part of the fundamental science that
needs to be done for us to even detect
these molecules in other planet
atmospheres or in the solar system let's
go deep into what you actually do uh
because my audience is the brightest in
the known Multiverse and just a reminder
we're talking to a doctor Sarah Rimer
who's got a list of awards that would
take me two or three podcasts to note uh
someday I'd love to talk to you about
the awards that you won for uh for
public understanding and uh for
leadership the rosin Franklin
lectureship prize in 2019 that was the
same one that the my kids favorite
astronomer named Brian Brian Cox uh he
won uh you won you know these these
phenomenal accolades but uh tell me what
they're for is it just for you know
doing something cool what are you do on
a daily basis do you use a telescope are
you looking at spectrographs are you
doing calibration are you building what
are you doing and how can other people
expect to follow in your footstep how
would they go about following in your
footsteps or doing the type of
day-to-day work that you do so what I do
is Theory so there are people who are
interested in observations say finding
observations of these exoplanets and I
am also excited about that however we
are not yet to the point of being able
to detect bios signatures and what
really griffed my interest as a
scientist is could we detect life on
another planet and when I entered grad
school the answer was this detection is
really decades away and even still like
we're just approaching the technological
Horizon where we might be able to see
the atmospheres of three habitable
exoplanets with jwst so we're really
just pushing that observational
threshold and so what I do is Theory to
try to understand how can we be sure of
the detection how can we think of false
positive mechanisms how clear would the
signal be would it overlap with other
features what kind of resolution do you
need how big of a telescope do you need
so that we can create future missions
these kind of horizon missions beyond
jwst that are really tailored for making
these measurements so as part of that
I'm part of this uh life mission Concept
in Europe called large interferometer
for exoplanets LF life and this would be
something that could actually detect
hundreds you know or maybe we're hoping
for like 30 50 maybe 100 earthlike
planets and characterize their
atmospheres and we and it's also in the
infrared where more of these molecules
absorb so I'm interested in both pushing
forward this sort of mission concept
which I'm a part of the team for but
then on my research side I look at how
does the star influence our observations
how does stellar activity influence our
observations so I do more theoretical
computational modeling that hopefully
will feed into and make our telescopes
uh more robust for what we want to
detect if you haven't read Andy Weir's
most recent book project Hal Mary you
you will love it yeah it's actually yeah
and you you could get it like your book
audible is actually better than any
other way to get it because it's
actually acted out by a by a Phenom by a
phenomenal actor with sound effects Etc
Andy we uh I'll put a link to the
episode that he was on on into the
impossible podcast I thank him for going
very deep and we even got into like
mental health issues and I watch that
one yeah why he dropped out of UC San
Diego without a degree and you know he
he went on to some success I guess you
could say but he talks about you know
obviously he's most well known for the
Martian for now although I think this is
even a better book but when we think
about uh these places that people tend
to look for life it's typically been
Mars uh and So lately I want to ask you
about uh two items in the news in your
in your Cricket pitch I don't know we'd
say ballpark when you're back in the US
uh but Cricket pitch I don't know but
anyway uh the point is uh there's been a
lot of interest in extraterrestrial uh
you know findings including on Venus and
on potentially on Venus and potentially
from this techno signature that uh your
former you know uh Harvard mate Avi lobe
talks about in uua as a techno signature
in his new book um that we also did an
interview with not too long ago so I
want to ask you first of all what is the
step what is your opinion uh of omua mua
and as a technos signature do you agree
with AI and his 80 papers on the subject
it's not like he just wrote one paper
and you know and then he wrote a book
and went on Joe Rogan show and uh and
then afterwards he worked his way up to
the into the impossible podcast but tell
me what is as a professional what what
do you make of this right so for amua I
haven't followed all of the recent
articles that have been written on
alternative explanations I'll I'll be
honest I know that many papers have been
published that are more critical of the
finding and I think more importantly is
there is this this phenomenon when we
have low resolution data what is it
called is it like the Cornelia effect or
something like this we should we could
figure it out um but basically when
there's this there's this famous crater
on Mars and it looks like a happy face
and and then when you and then when you
get a better image of it the happy face
disappears and humans do this all the
time we see things when we have low
resolution data and the data for amua
mua is just low resolution it's not it's
just the error bars are high we it only
had one pass we just couldn't get enough
information for it so while I agree with
AI that we should look for more of these
and definitely we should spend some of
our astronomical budget looking for more
of these because if he's correct in the
number of these then we should see more
of them and we should be able to do
better follow-up observations on them
with more time and actually see what
they are I disagree that it's a strong
evidence of life I think it's more
likely to be uh some of these other
these other explanations that um and
it's kind of like looking with the lamp
post under the lamp post I think uh you
know like all scientists we can fall
prey to our favorite hypothesis and then
kind of discount evidence that believes
that so so my my personal uh scientific
view on that is that there's enough kind
of holes in that theory to not claim
aliens so doesn't reach the robustness
of say aliens and then I would say the
same is true for Venus so uh we we we
don't even think it might be phosphine
you know maybe it is it's like these
these papers are still coming out back
and forth and the teams are you know
analyzing data new teams are reanalyzing
and saying no it's so SO2 and then
people are like no but you have an error
in your pipeline and so you you have
this back and forth which is why science
is awesome because it is prone to
falsification you have to repeat the
experiment and and I you know think that
if we do find you know first off we'll
have to see if it is phosphine it looks
less and less likely it is phosphine
there was a recent paper that shows the
water activity in in those uh clouds is
very low and water activity basically
means could life do the chemistry with
water you know is there enough water
there for it to to be functional and
it's a 100 times lower than any known
extremophile life that we know on Earth
Earth so there's a number of kind of
holes that are getting poked into the
Venus hypothesis or even just whereas if
it is phosphine maybe it's coming from a
different part of the atmosphere all of
these things matter and so to me it's
kind of like looking at these UFO videos
you can't just like look at something
fuzzy and be like oh that looks like a
UFO you have to get the the followup
data or if it is a UFO you don't
necessarily claim aliens I mean I've
seen some weird night uh night skylights
and and then in the end just happened to
be that the it was a military plane
taking off near me And it flew over
eventually and I was like oh it's a
plane but from a distance it was doing
all sorts of weird like geometrical
right angle stuff and if I you know if I
wasn't being skeptical I might have uh
claimed that I was seeing something odd
and so so I think uh the criteria you
know the same old like the age-old
expression that Carl San popularized you
know extraordinary claims require
extraordinary evidence and none of these
so far have met that hurdle yeah I
always say and you reference Michael
Shermer in the book and he's been on the
show many times good friend of mine and
yeah this kind of believing brain
phenomenon that you fill in the gaps
when there is this uh there is this
noise and and very low signal to noise
environment where there's very high
stakes you know it's one thing if you're
like looking for a seagull or as you
talk about looking for a a fly in front
of a spotlight you know it's not going
to probably kill you you might not a to
see it but oh if you see if it's a bat
you know we I encountered a bat the
other day and really freaked out my my
kids and and my wife but but anyway I
was kind of intrigued by it because
they're they're so interesting these
flying rats and you don't see them so
much in California but anyway yeah uh
but yeah there's a much bigger
consequence I suppose for that to happen
but yeah I wanted to to bring up this
this recent very provocative you know
tweet and and of course Sabina Hassen
Felder who's a good friend of mine and
past guest many Time guest on the show
uh she tweeted out you know almost a
sense of Glee uh that the max plank
Institute in in Germany uh for solar
system research and guten tweeted out
phosphine in Venus's clouds No Trace
it's pretty rare um like even with the
bicep 2 Affair you you might be familiar
might not be but for my listeners you
know we didn't like make a blunder we
didn't leave the lens cap on or like
that somebody had a SM we detected
extremely high levels of signal to noise
of B mode polarization and it's no
disagreeing with that it's just how we
attributed it what was the source of it
this is now saying it seems to be quite
different it seems to be saying more in
the camp of almost like the Opera faster
than like neutrinos or something like
there was there's actually something
wrong with the original analysis these
people are so AR I'm gonna have Jane on
I hope Jane griev Professor Greaves on
maybe sarasa back for a part two or
something as well what do you make of
this it's it's pretty astounding to see
this huge basic flip-flop from you know
scientific Community we need more data
to now we don't need any more data and
we probably should focus more effort on
you know other planets go back to Mars
you know as our folk as our Focus so
what do you think of it this extreme 180
degree flip in the scientific Community
not in the public for any of these
claims that are extraordinary you will
get people trying different explanations
and and trying to redo the data and
that's what you want uh I think you have
the same sort of sensationalized uh
article Journal article titles after the
Allen Hills meteorite claim as well and
after some of these other controversies
you know I think one of them was like
Tempest in a teapot you know I mean so
so scientists can come up with uh you
know very Sensational uh headlines on
our own without the media but I think no
matter what Venus is a story that we
should pay attention to because it's
certainly a humbling lesson as we think
about exoplanets just given the amount
of back and forth on on this uh
detection exoplanets are much further
away Venus is next door if we have
trouble understanding it how are we
going to understand these planets
orbiting distant stars but then also you
know there are this I would be curious
to see what Jane has to say as well as
I'd recommend inviting uh Dr Clara Silva
who is the theorist and who's the main
person who came up with phosphine as a
bios signature in her from her PhD work
so you know because there are different
ways and polinomial fits to this data
and depending on your assumptions you
can get different results and so I think
that we have to see how this plays out
we know one thing is that the Greaves
team has taken their uh abundance
estimate down a notch from the 20 parts
per what is a billion to I think one
part per billion so we'll just have to
see but they still think they're seeing
phosphine and so you know they're it's
going to go back and forth and whether
or not it's phosphine or SO2 is
interesting and if it is even if it's a
little bit of phosphine that is unusual
and that would indicate some atmospheric
chemistry that we're not really uh
understanding or some geological process
we're not understanding because I don't
think it's life Venus is a very hellish
world like just complex chemistry is
going to have a hard time surviving
there so so then the question is what is
it if it is just SO2 I still think we
should go back to Venus because we don't
understand Venus just as a kind of a
side note to this Colin uh Wilson here
at Oxford said that at a conference a
Venus conference they had eight groups
take the same boundary conditions in
their climate models for Venus and with
eight different climate models and every
group had a different atmosphere for
Venus come out so we just can't model
Venus's atmosphere very well yet we
don't understand the Dynamics we don't
understand these more thicker
atmospheres yet very well and we're
going to need to as we start looking for
exoplanets so I think Venus is
interesting for us on our way to
understanding other planets no matter
what the story ends up being a lot of
the book's most juicy and delightful
passages that you wrote again I'm
talking with Dr soon to be Professor
Sarah Rimer about her research in her
wonderful book searching for
extraterrestrial life audible exclusive
and you'll see a review there among 70
other reviews uh from yours truly uh
with a with an asterism of of five stars
we are celebrating the 60th anniversary
of the Drake equation this year 2021 and
tried to get Frank Drake on he's pushing
90 he yeah he had such a polite you know
declination a
declining rejection I should say of my
invit it was so polite so classy I love
him so much but I'm not a huge fan of
his equation for the following reason
that you actually point out in your
wonderful audio book which is that you
know we presented Drake equation in a
way that if one of our undergraduates my
undergraduates your future
undergraduates if they were ever to
submit a result and it had no error
analysis associated with it we would
give it back to them with an F right but
the Drake equation is always presented
as if you know it's just an equation out
pops a number and then you just go but
you point out as you know it in the book
as I pointed out I gave a talk at the
city Institute that we have to do error
analysis as and that's the hard part of
being a scientist right you you talked
about the just the F fos life a minute
ago so um but talk about that the the
lack of kind of attention that's paid to
the real meat of what you and I do which
is really in the in the details of of
how we look at as you described
systematic errors in particular and uh
and statistical errors so first of all
what's a what's a systematic error and
how can it plague results such as you
know estimates based on the Drake
equation with the Drake equation just in
general when we think about the errors
we really only know the first few terms
with any sort of certainty and then
we're so limited in our understanding of
earth type life in fact the equation
itself is very astronom focused if a
biologist were writing this equation it
would probably be different you know and
they might think of different steps uh
that would be more interesting to put in
the equation so we could just be wrong
in where we're looking for life we could
have you know this bias of G stars for
example we're around a sunlike star but
most of the stars in the universe are M
stars is that a statistical fluke that
we just happen to be around a star type
that's only 6% of the stars or or is it
is there something there is it that
stars have some these cooler red stars
have some intrinsic flaw as um habital
Planet hosts so we don't know a lot of
these things and until we get more
observations of of planets it's it's
kind of like it it seems to me beyond my
imaginative scientific Horizon to be
able to pin down the the terms of the
Drake equation because especially like
the last term the lifetime of an
intelligent civilization I mean you
could put whatever number you want in
there how are we going to have some
statistical answer unless we have meet a
being that has traveled the full
Universe maybe even the Multiverse and
we can say give us the answers to this
equation I don't think we're going to be
able to come up with that for the
foreseeable future but it's still
interesting I think it's interesting as
a concept it's interesting as a well how
do we try to narrow down with a you know
astronomer love back of the order of
calculations could we do something
useful from that and I guess it's these
same sorts of back of the envelope
calculations that turned me away from
astronomy when I was a physics
undergraduate student I'm like they
don't know anything to within like
factors of you know hundred or
more and and so but at the same time now
as an astronomer I I do see some use for
it it's just not the I think what people
might think oh we can say that there
must be millions of intelligent
civilizations in the Galaxy no we we
have no idea because we have no idea how
common life is how common complex life
is how come an intelligent life is
technological life and how long it lasts
I mean we just have no idea yeah and I I
do want to conclude with uh sort of a
statement that I think you know your job
is made harder in many ways by the
media as you know kind of this this
machine but sometimes it's even our
professional colleagues who who also
take a liberty and make posters of gas
or gisa whatever however you pronounce
you talk about in the book these posters
they're very whims
and but then you know people start to
think like is that looks really you know
photo realistic is that a real picture
of the planet and and my colleague Adam
burgasser I'm sure you know here and and
he worked on the trapist results and you
know you get these posters outside their
office I'm like yeah that might be kind
of cool to take a vacation there H but I
I think it does make things pretty hard
especially when you realize that there
are so you know few pieces of tangible
physical evidence and when we get a
little bit we just pour over it and I
want to ask you about kind of the answer
to the ultimate mystery in all of your
field which is the fmy Paradox you know
where is everybody but to hear Sarah's
answers you're gonna have to subscribe
to her podcast and my podcast and I'm
gonna send out uh your answers to these
questions and more to my mailing list so
you have to subscribe to Brian king.com
my mailing list you'll get the answers
to the thrilling three questions in
which I'm going to ask Sarah about the
her answer to the fmy Paradox and also
you can get it by subscribing to her
podcast and leaving a review wherever
podcasts are sold and that is called CH
self-care with doctors Sarah because you
do that with your friend Sarah B uh
remind me remind me Sarah's the last
name again I I keep forgetting sah
Ballard Professor Sarah
Ballard she's at Florida yes I want to
have her on too she's coming to the UK
in a week so we could do you know double
double Sarah's while she's here for two
weeks so now if you want to hear the
answers to the thrilling three final
questions including where is everybody
in the universe you're going to have to
subscribe to Sarah's Dr Sarah's podcast
plural professors now Sarah podcast and
uh subscribe to Brian king.com my
mailing list so for now thank you for
joining us going into the impossible
with Professor Sarah Ruger thank you
Sarah